[Music]
schizophrenia was first identified more
than a century ago but we still don't
know it's exact causes it remains one of
the most misunderstood and stigmatized
illnesses today so let's walk through
what we do know from symptoms to causes
and treatments schizophrenia is
considered a syndrome which means it may
encompass a number of related disorders
that have similar symptoms but varying
causes every person with schizophrenia
has slightly different symptoms and the
first signs can be easy to miss subtle
personality changes irritability or a
gradual encroachment of unusual thoughts
patients are usually diagnosed after the
onset of psychosis which typically
occurs in the late teens or early 20s
for men and the late 20s or early 30s
for women a first psychotic episode can
feature delusions hallucinations and
disordered speech and behavior these are
called positive symptoms meaning they
occur in people with schizophrenia but
not in the general population it's a
common misperception that people with
schizophrenia have multiple
personalities but these symptoms
indicate a disruption of thought
processes rather than the manifestation
of another personality schizophrenia
also has negative symptoms these are
qualities that are reduced in people
with schizophrenia such as motivation
expression of emotion or speech there
are cognitive symptoms as well like
difficulty concentrating remembering
information and making decisions so what
causes the onset of psychosis there
likely isn't one single cause but a
combination of genetic and environmental
risk factors that contribute
schizophrenia has some of the strongest
genetic links of any psychiatric illness
though about 1% of people have
schizophrenia children or siblings of
people with schizophrenia are 10 times
likelier to develop the disease
and an identical twin of someone with
schizophrenia has a 40% chance of being
affected often immediate relatives of
people with schizophrenia exhibit milder
versions of traits associated with the
disorder but not to an extent that
requires treatment multiple genes almost
certainly play a role but we don't know
how many or which ones environmental
factors like exposure to certain viruses
in early infancy might increase the
chance that someone will develop
schizophrenia and use of some drugs
including marijuana may trigger the
onset of psychosis and highly
susceptible individuals these factors
don't affect everyone the same way for
those with very low genetic risk no
amount of exposure to environmental risk
factors will lead them to develop
schizophrenia for those with very high
risk moderate additional risk might tip
the balance the antipsychotic drugs used
to treat schizophrenia have helped
researchers work backwards to trace
signatures of the disorder in the brain
traditional antipsychotics block
dopamine receptors they can be very
effective in reducing positive symptoms
which are linked to an excess of
dopamine in particular brain pathways
but the same drugs can make negative
symptoms worse and we've found that
negative symptoms of schizophrenia may
be tied to too little dopamine in other
brain areas some people with
schizophrenia show a loss of neural
tissue and it's unclear whether this
atrophy is a result of the disease
itself or drug induced suppression of
signaling
fortunately newer generations of
antipsychotics aim to address some of
these issues by targeting multiple
neurotransmitters like serotonin in
addition to dopamine it's clear that no
one transmitter system is responsible
for all symptoms and because these drugs
effects signaling throughout the brain
and body they can have other side
effects like weight gain
in spite of these complications
antipsychotics can be very effective
especially when combined with other
interventions like cognitive behavioral
therapy electroconvulsive therapy though
it provides relatively short-lived
relief is also reimagine as an effective
treatment especially when other options
have failed early intervention is also
extremely important after months or
years of untreated psychosis certain
psychosis can become embedded in
someone's personality and yet the
dehumanizing stigma attached to this
diagnosis can prevent people from
seeking help people with schizophrenia
are often perceived as dangerous but are
actually much more likely to be the
victims of violence than the
perpetrators and proper treatment may
help reduce the likelihood of violence
associated with schizophrenia that's why
education for patients their families
and their communities helps erode the
stigma and improves access to treatment
continue to educate yourself about the
symptoms causes and treatments of
different mental health conditions with
this playlist
[Music]